anyone who's taken even a few taxi rides
in Germany is sure to have ridden in an
eClass Mercedes as the taxi drivers
favorite model a good many of the more
than 13 million a classes that Mercedes
has sold to date have served as cabs
they have a reputation as being highly
robust some are even said to have
clocked up 700,000 kilometers or more
what sex change a scenery that goes to
Portugal where the weather is noticeably
warmer and where Mercedes is presenting
its new generation eClass car testa
Sacha Kopp realizes that many viewers
will be reminded of a taxi and in this
model the driver quickly starts feeling
more like a passenger but the question
is what the driver really want that
Mercedes is w213 series the latest
generation is a completely new model not
just a facelift at 4 meters 92 it's even
a bit longer than its predecessor it was
launched on the European market with
three engine options a 135 kilowatt
gasoline-powered and two diesel engines
we tested the smaller diesel the e 220 D
model with 143 kilowatts of power it
takes seven point three seconds to hit
100 km/h from zero with fuel consumption
rated at four point three liters per 100
kilometers the lower rpms make for less
noise in the dual acoustic glass for
even less at extra cost of course also
new as the drive pilot assisted driving
system it doesn't drive the car but
supports the still active driver Sascha
is going to try out the cars semi
autonomous driving system it's available
up to 210 km/h on the highway but it's
supposed to work for city driving as
well 210 km/h isn't allowed in Portugal
so he'll start off a bit more leisurely
he pulls this lever on the steering
column twice to switch the system on he
can take both feet off the pedals and
even let go of the wheel and it actually
stays in the lane on its own the drivers
should keep both hands on the wheel
after all he's in control not Mercedes
the driver can set the distance to other
cars on the road with the same lever the
drive pilot uses sensors and cameras to
detect road markings and other cars so
even in stop-and-go traffic in town the
Mercedes can pace the car in front as if
on an invisible towline the system can
recognize and keep the lane without
markings up to 130 km/h Sascha explains
that the new drive pilot also supports
automatic lane changing this means the
driver has the option of changing lanes
simply by activating the turn signal
lever all you have to do is hold it for
two seconds in the direction you want to
go and the car itself carries out the
maneuver
the driver may not have even seen the
overtaking car but the driver will have
already had a fix on it and brakes off
its own passing maneuver and the driver
can try again right away by holding the
lever for two seconds well that's what I
you light it another function made
possible by the interaction between the
traffic scientists is cameras and the
drive pilot is the speed limit pilot an
idea originally introduced by Ford the
system automatically reads speed limits
and reduces the speed of necessary such
equips the one thing this Mercedes
probably won't do is pay any speeding
tickets the driver might get my god
driver stops reacting at all the car
will sound an alert quickly bring itself
to a stop and turn the flashers on but
it won't leave the lane by itself
because it has no way of knowing what
the surface there is like and if the car
started swerving it could be a real
problem
sascha points out that the drive pilot
does not come cheap it runs about 2,800
euros on top of the price of an eClass
it would take a lot of taxi driving to
cover the added cost in the cabin a
screen resembling an outsized iPhone
takes up almost the entire instrument
panel sasha explains the mercedes is now
moving away from a dash mounted display
to an integrated two component display
one for the instruments and one for
navigation both are on a twelve point
three inch screen and it's very tempting
to try to adjust something that only
leaves grease spots the actual switches
are built into the steering wheel plus a
touchpad and a dial but there are so
many shiny surfaces on the console that
you need a rag handy to wipe the dust
and fingerprints away after a while that
gets to be something of a pain the bad
news is that neither the sat-nav nor the
digital displays are standard the base
version comes with a conventional round
instruments it feels like having a tube
TV set instead of a flat screen
Daimler's reasoning is that it has to
offer a stripped-down bass version for
the taxi drivers observes that no matter
who drives this e-class there are
occasions when you need to take more
than one passenger and then you need
space in the back especially if it's a
taxi but unlike what Sasha was expecting
the back seat doesn't have that much
room the 10th generation may have added
7 centimeters to its wheelbase but they
don't seem to have gone into more
legroom his knees are pressed against
the front seats and the Headroom is less
than adequate
you know Sasha sums up saying the new
e-class --is active steering takes some
getting used to at high speeds the
driver has to build a level of trust in
the car for him personally the starting
price is a bit too steep especially
since it includes none of the high-tech
gadgetry he's hoping the drive pilot
will eventually find its way into other
Mercedes models then he might find one
right for him